ボカッ
辛いのは苦手なんですよでも辛いのってレベルじゃないですかもう
このレベルまでいくとから来てもううわーってなるやつがあるんですけども
俺の中のそのギリギリライン夏ほどカラフルーツなんですよ田辺市長は本当に美味しく
食べれるレベルですちょうどいい感じにか別に言うとちょっと辛いかなぐらいマジで
辛くて美味しいのないんです僕のすごい今回はこう
ウイティアさんがちょっとねご依頼が来まして2010年9月税は遺産10周年増え
てく数値はあらゆる施策
cm とか web サイズとペッパーインスタント web ムービー
c 商品発売とかで日本ツアーから不調でいっぱいにしてしまおうと
日本全国から穴を計画という分強く
日本全国から免職計画というプロジェクトを示しました
そのプロジェクトの集大成と言える本キャンペーンでは実際にこれを書けば何でも
カラフルツアーズにしてしまうという
colors 著そしてカラムーチョパウダーおよびがすべて山月9日より
キャンペーンをスタートさせたということでございます本キャンペーンは満を持して
この川口パウダーを商品化し
ちゃんと動いた湖池屋の会長できたら営業部長が世の中そんなに甘くない辛いんだと
商品化に待ったをかけられてほしいですこれだめだとちょっと待っていると言われた
らしいですそこで攻撃や会長は力から営業部長がっ透過させるために保育やさんの会場
が食べておりたんですけども脱力させるために革靴パウダーの商品化がありか
なしか国民の皆様にぜひよということになるらしいです
この家具茶パウダーが商品化されるかどうかは俺立つ次第にかかっているわけだ
なんで今回は実際にちわねこれを使ってほんっ
これがありかなしかというと僕確認しますじゃあまずびっくりステから米処
ちょっと各ブースじゃないよ時前から発売からも30周年です
後藤さんメンツも食ってたのほかおいています全てのものから打ちね志摩子のパーム
ちょパウダーこれが果たしてあるが確かっていうの
いろんな食べ物にこれをかけても実際に使えるどうぞ姉貴を試してみたいと話す
とりあえずみんなどう思うかしらねーよみんな道具するねーけど俺の1コで
そして今回はありかなしかをちょっと言わせていただきますかな月は好きなんですよ
あととか考えただけで中妻が止まる普通に技をいただきます
ん
うんん
美味しいた名著同じ味がするフォルトばだけな奴が
アズラーもまさにから2です何だろうこのなんか管理ちょっと言っとんなくなるんだよ
ねやっぱり全然金具ちょっとあなたは完璧にカラムーチョのあずになってます問題は
ここからなんですよ
世の中のいろんな食べ物があるだろそれにこれをかけてアリかナシかっていう話なん
ですよこれだけがを意識でもあり話
決まらない時はいろんなものにかけてみようと思いますじゃあまずあ白ご飯からいき
ます
アーマー酒子どもが自分で汁ご飯を炊くとは
すいません電子レンジで作りました
が何っ
うーんちょっとかけ付けちゃってるなるかもしれないですねこれ以外ですねまずは
ちょっとこういうふりかけ的な30食べてみます
れております
なんというかもうちょっと義務チっぽい感じです何かごはんにキムチを漬けた感じです
愛で全然気がしてきますこれはある夜ご飯は鍼です
次は焼きそばです
7役その次の国ですから今後はちょっと厳しくいきたいですね程よい辛さだと
めちゃくちゃ嬉しいです
僕みたいに辛すぎるのが苦手な人はちょびっと書けるくらいでも全然味が変わると思い
ます
じゃ最後版で影すぎて汗がちゃんいただきます
焼きそばかけるからぐちょ
優勝本当に家ですぎや
なんかもうちょいっと書けるのかなーやっぱあれは技から銘茶な花見というか絶妙な
感じで早実おいしいよ
生まれるこれまでは何です
これはまずありで本当に美味しかった
次はそちらパッティングですパスタ難しいと思うからポスティングであれば塩コショウ
を
から口3点を調味料の何かだいねえ終点かれる気がします
の的に色的にちょっと画面じゃわかりづらいと思うんですけど結構応援準備なっちゃい
ましたちなみこのバスター自分でつくったからねそもそもパスタがまずいってその性も
ある
言うまでもないバレエバーでアイマス絶妙な圧の変化の理由まずソースだけに入って
自分のスパ急ぎますに足を踏み入れからように現れた金具パーツも絶妙な酸味はと誘い
てから月文字ご視聴を止めるわけでもなく王者を食べに明日の良さを共通者にクロス
まさに赤も祭
なんでもないです
次はこちらなっしゅまろですは島まであったらの外受験させましたねーなー
うわぁとしっかりまぁこんなもんでしょ花咲くイース母さん見て量産型たかやって
どっちが勝つかっていうねもうね合う合わないとかのレベルじゃないです勝負です
いただきます
うーんずっと海と戦ってるんそれがちょっとカラムーチョの欲しいかなまぁそれがね
先攻取ってガーっても登っていったんですけど広範囲に渡る攻撃呼びこのフィールド上
のほとんどがまあからグッズが制圧して上手に来詰め寄られていて最終的に腹別のかつ
です
こちら
なうですまあちょっとデザート2番がで初っ端しかないわけですよ
ぼぼぼぼぼーのものを蹴って
です
うん
ん
というわけでいかがだったでしょうかカラムーチョパウダー最後のほうはちょっと
ふざけちゃったんですけどもご飯として食べるようなものにはとても合っていたと思い
ます
ありがとうございます
はぁだけでもすごい好きでいつでもどこでもカラムーチョが楽しめるって言うからです
ね
山路生まれて感じで僕はから打つパウダーありだと思ってます本キャンペーンではあり
がナシかをキャンペーンサイトで投票してくれた方は10,000名様に
実際に商品化すべく進めていたカラーずつパウダーの日にパックをプレゼントします
この投票の結果次第でこの金具ず体が商品化されるかされないか始まるので一目指しに
代わって料
やっぱ
食べすぎは体によやったね僕の動画も見てねこのから打つならアリと思ったかなしと
思ったから
下の好評のところによかったら投票してみてください
僕はありだと思いましてましてや世界塔ですダイエットだな
ぜひアリかナシか答えてみてくださいねこういうくんありがとう湖池屋さんありがとう
じゃあな